Many of us REMEMBER things for exams because
we learn them without context.
And, to learn without context is what we call
rote learning.
So what if I told you that you don’t need
to remember things?
It’s possible if we try to understand the
core concepts!
And to learn or to understand, we need to
first start by asking the right questions.
For example, instead of asking ‘WHY are
there no real humans in Don't memorise videos’,
we could ask, ‘WHO are the humans behind
these videos?
Hey guys, my name is Zarina and I am the voice
behind all the videos that you see on this
channel.
We have an army of animators, illustrators
and educators who help us create them.
And, it all began with Ganesh and Rohan
Hi! I’m Ganesh.
Hi, I’m Rohan.
Let me begin by telling you why I started
Don't Memorise. A few years ago I told my dad that I want
to be a teacher and I want to teach hundreds
of students over the next five years.
To which he replied “Hundreds isn’t cool
you know what’s cool?
“millions”?
And, that's why I started this YouTube channel.
And I decided to join him in this journey,
because I strongly believe in the company’s
goal to be the BEST TEACHERS out there.
We make videos ranging from school level math
and science to test prep content, and we’ve
started adding some brain teaser videos as well.
We believe that true learning not just helps
you in your exams but in your real life too!
So we asked each other “how would we define
real success”?
If a million students end up saying, 'I’ve
become a better person because of Don't Memorise',
that would mean real success for us.
Finally, we would like to thank all of you
for watching our videos, giving us your feedback,
and participating in our contests.
If you feel that there are others who could
benefit from our content, don't forget to
share our videos with them.
And as always, do share your thoughts with
us in the comments section below.
We love to hear from you.
To subscribe to our channel, click on the
atom you see here.
And to watch an interesting video, click on
the Newton’s cradle there.